Here's the perspective matrix formed from the 3JS parameters, the numbers in
the upper left three by three are scale factors, similar to how the
orthographic projection works, though the z scale's a little different. There's
also a translation factor for z. However, the big differences here are that
there's a negative one in the last row. And the lower right corner now has a
zero. I'm not going to derive this projection formula here. Most good 3D
graphics texts run through this process. Also be aware that for some
formulations, the near and far values are negative since you're traveling down
the negative z axis. The one headache of keeping things in a right handed
system is the whole plus is the axis points at the viewer problem. I'm using
positive near and far values in this matrix, because that's how 3JS specifies
things and thank heavens for that. In fact these two values must be positive
numbers for the perspective transform. You can see things would get weird if
the near value for example was somewhere behind the camera. For orthographic
projections we can use whatever numbers we want for near and far. Even negative
values since we're really just selecting a box in space. For perspective we're
doing something more elaborate with transforming space so these values must be
positive. The interesting thing is how this perspective matrix works with
coordinates. Let's take a nice simple case. Field of view 90 degrees, aspect
ratio one. near 1 and far 11. This gives us this matrix. Let's use this matrix
on some test points and see what we get.